I made a square hole in the sheet of paper,
and a coaster, a circular coaster.
I fold the paper in a mysterious fashion,
and I can pass the coaster
through the hole, really passes
both directions, and I haven't started cheating.
It really is going through the hole. And yet
when I put these out, the diameter of the coaster
is bigger than the diagonal of the square hole.
What is going on? I didn't stretch and didn't tear.
And yet when I fold the sheet back,
in a judicious way,
the coaster does go through,
the coaster which is bigger than the hole.
How is this possible?
I am willing to give away the secret for free,
on this special occasion. It has to do with
the interplay between,
the intrinsic, or inner dimension, of the sheet of paper
which is 2 dimensions. And the fact that the sheet evolves
and flourishes in the ambient 3 dimensional space.
There is some elbow-room, there is some ambient space.
So dimension 2 and dimension 3. In the following sense.
First, I can fold the paper in a naive way like this,
in which case the largest gap
that I can try to pass the disc through, is this gap.
That used to be, as you can see,
the diagonal the square hole, and
that was too small for the disc to pass through.
But that's not the only thing that we do. Now, I take
this sheet of paper, and start twisting it
until those two sides get aligned
into a straight line. And as I do this,
as I twist the ends, you can see that the
part of the paper starts raising above the floor.
That's escaping into the 3rd dimension,
taking advantage of the fact there is extra room there.
And when those two sides align completely
then I can squash and crease. And, by the way,
when I do that, I should shift by one
in order to create this gap. Now the gap that we have
created then is this gap, which is larger
than the previous gap, because this gap used to be
not the diagonal, but the sum of those two sides.
And if you remember Pythagoras, you have
gained an extra factor of square root of 2, which is a bit more than 40%.
So the secret of success when you make this toy
is to drill out the hole, so that the diagonal
is slightly shorter than the diameter
of the disc which is for surprise,
but the sum of the two sides is slightly longer than this diameter.
And that's possible because there's
that extra of window 40%.
And this is all possible, because when we
do this maneuver, you're allowing the whole thing to come out
into 3D, and then come back down.
This fact that you can escape into the ambient
3rd dimension and come back in, this
extra journey that you are making into the extra degree of freedom
gives you this wonderful magic.
[ROBOT NOISES]